[Musique]
d'importantes mesures aux normes du
travail entre en vigueur aujourd'hui des
changements à la loi sur les normes du
travail comme on l'a dit et pour savoir
ce qu'ils en aient j'en parle avec
marianne plamondon qui est avocate
spécialisée en droit de l'emploi est
également du travail bonjour ma lampe la
moto est là c'est important vraiment
donc ça rentre en vigueur aujourd'hui et
on a entendu le savez beaucoup ce
mouvement mis tout le mouvement moi
aussi il ya des dispositions concernant
notamment le harcèlement psychologique
et sexuelle à l'intérieur des
entreprises en jeu certains également
qu'en savoie interpeller les gens la
maison mais tout à fait en fait le
projet de loi avait été adoptée le 12
juin 2000
2018 et c'est des nouvelles les
nouvelles dispositions y avait certaines
dispositions qui rentre en vigueur sur
le chat en matière de harcèlement on a
ajouté la définition d'harcèlement
sexuel dès le 12 juin dernier dans
l'obligation de l'employeur de jerry et
de prévenir le ce type de harcèlement
également et aussi on avait changé le
délai pour porter plainte parce qu'on
avait vue dans la foulée du grenelle de
l' est allongé exactement deux ans alors
qu'auparavant on parlait de 92 92 ou
plutôt rapide
donc si un employé vit des choses celle
au travail ça et qu'il doit quitter son
emploi et c'est pas des samares facile
mais des fois de porter plainte donc en
allongeant le délai on espérait de cette
façon là qu'on aurait plus de
dénonciation et plus de plaintes mais
dans aujourd'hui donc c'est que là je
veux bien qu'on fasse une obligation
pour les entreprises d'avoir cette
politique contre le harcèlement
mais la politique c'est à partir
d'aujourd'hui jean que la politique est
obligatoire donc on a laissé le temps
aux empereurs de se préparer depuis juin
je vous avez le temps de se préparer
et là c'est aujourd'hui ça entre en
vigueur pour les employeurs qui n'ont
pas toujours toujours pas rédiger leur
politique là il faut vraiment accélérer
le pas alors que ce soit applicable dès
la réouverture des bureaux donc
habituellement demain habituellement
demain est aussi une traitement des
plaintes qui remplace exactement donc la
politique doit convenir différents
volets premièrement d'avoir une des
mécanismes de prévention pour qu'on
parle de prévention on va parler de la
formation en milieu de travail
s'assurer que les gens ont lu la
politique qui s'engagent à la respecter
mais aussi de la formation au niveau de
la civilité au travail certains
comportements de nos jours ne sont plus
acceptables alors que dans une autre
époque pouvait l'être
donc on incite les employeurs à former
leurs employés et par ailleurs processus
de traitement des plaintes à dire
lorsqu'une plainte on peut s'assurer
d'abord le professionnel qui compétents
kit objectifs et qui fait la lumière sur
les faits de façon à pouvoir
véritablement régler la problématique et
en prévenir d'autres
bon si vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs les
moeurs ont changé et très très
rapidement poésie est ce que les
entreprises ont suivi lors des dernières
années mais c'est sûr que les ans pour
les entreprises sophistiqués avaient
déjà des politiques en place
certaines d'entre elles avaient des
politiques et des systèmes de prévention
de gestion de leurs seulement très très
efficace certains d'autres moins mais
c'est c'est sûr qu'on ajoute à cet
élément là dans la nouvelle loi sur les
normes bon s'assure que les employeurs
réfléchissent à ces questions-là repense
à leur façon de gérer ces situations là
et c'est sûr que dans la foulée du
mouvement mis tous dorénavant c'est une
question qui monte au conseil
d'administration les questions
d'harcèlement personne n'a le goût de
faire la une des médias à cause de
situations fâcheuses d'harcèlement
sexuel au travail dont il ya la question
de l'harcèlement sexuel harcèlement
psychologique mais il ya d'autres
changements également dans les normes du
travail je regardais ça encore là c'est
intéressant mais aussi vous les gens à
la maison il ya la question des congés
alors trois semaines de vacances
après trois semaines de service ça
commence aussi au jour d'aujourd'hui va
donc ceux qui ont cumulé et leur garder
votre nombre d'années d'ancienneté
ceux qui cumulent trois ans de service
continu dorénavant au lieu d'avoir deux
semaines de vacances vont avoir trois
semaines de vacances avant pour avoir
trois semaines de vacances fallait
attendre 50 services continue également
de congés payés maintenant dans la loi
sur les normes avant c'était dix jours
pour s'occuper de ses enfants si on
avait un accident ou une maladie
mais non on a deux jours pays sur ces
dix jours la sai également c'est un
ajout et l'autre chose c'est un une
journée de plus donc deux jours payer
maintenant en cas de deuil suite au
décès d'un proche
ce sera donc la question de laisser les
projets à se marier ces cinq jours que
le travailleur peut s'absenter va
toucher deux journées les guider alors
c'est important aussi là alors est-ce
qu'on prédit que les normes sont plus
permis s'ils vous donnent davantage
aussi de latitude pour l'employé bah en
fait sur certains et l'image parce qu'il
y avait de la pression sur différents
niveaux conciliation travail famille
c'était l'objectif donc sur certains
points oui sur d'autres puis un qui est
très important aussi qui entre en
vigueur aujourd'hui c'est au niveau du
droit de refus sadel employés ont le
droit de refuser s'il n'a pas cinq jours
à l'avant son horaire donc pour les
milieux où la demande change rapidement
et on peut pas prévoir nécessairement le
degré d'occupation dans ce cadre là ça
va être un bon casse tête pour les
employeurs de jerry tous les refus cinq
jours à l'avancé donc les emplois vont
devoir
sexy [ __ ]
alors certains éléments effectivement
améliore la qualité de vie de l'empereur
des employeurs mais certains éléments
également qu'ils étaient voulues par le
patronat tente rapidement si on veut
s'informer sur ces nouvelles chambres
sous ces changements à la recette
internet imagine aussi le site de la
cnss t mais également il ya le guide
pratique des changements la loi sont les
normes de leur décès est rachat qui est
disponible en ligne et qui extrêmement
complet avec toutes les données et
toutes les informations possibles je
pense que vous nous avez donné des shows
au départ de bonnes informations m
marianne plamondon merci beaucoup et
bonne année aussi bonne année